hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to we'll
see how the matrix clearly ripped off so
much Japan's most famous enemies Japan
decided they want to steal some of that
shit back
hence the enemy after the success of the
first matrix movie in in between filming
the Matrix sequels several animators and
storytellers including double jockeys
decide to get together and do a series
of shorts based on the idea of the
matrix the result is the Animatrix an
anthology that many claim is actually
better than the Matrix films themselves
in many respects they're kind of right
in others well let's just say the cell T
of the matrix mixed with the subtlety of
Japan is anything but so so let's take a
quick glance at one source material
stealing from another source material
this is the Animatrix the first one is
the final flight of the Osiris a CG
short written by the Wachowskis and by
does it show aside from the CGI looking
for the most part pretty damn impressive
especially when it comes to human
textures it has all the Wachowski
trademarks totally pointless action
scene check good-looking Bland's trying
to sound important but instead sounding
disinterested go go go
check horny sexual issues being explored
under the guise of avant-garde
storytelling double check the story is
the Osiris has discovered a drill that
the machines have built to break into
Zion and I have to get that information
to Zion as fast as possible the matrix
for some reason is the only way they can
get that information to them does this
technological world hate phones for some
reason and they'll end up dying in the
process um sucks to be them it would be
nice if they actually let us oh I don't
know get to know these people so it felt
more important when they got axed off
but it's pretty obvious that's not the
shorts intention the intention like
anything related to the matrix is to be
an exercise in new technology and
looking cool and for a short it does
that fine you don't give a shit about
what happens to them but they look so
cool while you're not giving a shit
about what happens to them it's a fun
little demonstration of cool CGI effects
and some neat visuals
totally passable the next one however is
anything but short it's another one
written by the Wachowskis describing the
history of how the matrix came into
being and on the one hand it looks
amazing some of the imagery is downright
inspired and dripping with beautiful
animation with that said it still
doesn't excuse the fact that makes
little to no sense and it's still
deep-fried and pretentious banner I mean
like extra crispy pretentious batter the
story is told through the Zion archives
which looks like every religion was
smashed into a hologram card where they
reveal a past where humanity relied too
much on technology robots did all the
work and mankind just leaned back and
relaxed an interesting idea when
suddenly these machines with no motions
or thoughts of their own suddenly get
emotions and thoughts of their own it
happens I think my toaster is looking at
me funny this apparently spawns from one
of them murdering his owner because he
didn't want to be deleted course if
these things were supposed to be
programmed with emotions before it's
pretty obvious this what happened a long
time ago but because two popular
commentaries our life just happens and
man equals bad they decide they do
suddenly have feelings now but mankind
being stupid evil us decides to destroy
them all and doesn't care for their
emotions that may or may not be there
programmed in originally oh of a
confused manatee the surviving machines
create their own country and even though
they were banished from humanity somehow
still do humanity's work you still
following this there's a test later and
I can assure you I'm gonna fail it but
get this the machines economy does
better flinging the human economy out of
whack so again being big stupid evil us
we just decide to blow them all up
because man like boom and evil and
everything wrong but the machines
survived and decided they had enough so
they begin to enslave mankind so our big
dumb idiot commentary selves go to the
obvious logical conclusion destroy the
sky yeah because there's solar operated
this would apparently destroy them all
but even that doesn't work again totally
not explained why as the machines
finally enslave all of humanity and
eventually formed the matrix to feed off
of our energy I guess we suck by
so I'm just gonna come out and say it
the shock value in this is beyond
exploited there's some damn gritty
acknowledgments of nam the holocaust
street riots real crime scenes and they
tried to make them as disturbing and
gory as possible desperate to get some
sort of emotional reaction now don't get
me wrong I have nothing against intense
imagery if it's fit and it's deserving I
say go for it take us out of our comfort
zone before science fiction story it
doesn't really explain the science nor
the fiction in any logical sense we
can't get behind the emotion of it
because on top of there being no one to
connect with there's just no rational
progression to what's going on
commentary is supposed to explain why or
how something is the way it is whether
it seems more focused on getting an
emotional response with disturbing
imagery but no reason why but that's it
it is still something to admire just on
its visual ambition I could totally see
someone getting ideas for a stronger
project just based on his dramatic
layout but in terms of making any sense
or becoming emotionally invested this is
definitely not the place to look kids
story is the last of the Wachowski
written shorts and give a credit that it
at least attempts to make an emotional
connection this time or at least feel
something resembling an emotional
experience most of it focuses on a high
school boy who spends his time on the
computer trying to follow the path neo
and Trinity left behind
eventually neo gets in contact and
agents try to catch him we have a long
chase scene and in the end he literally
makes a leap of faith and somehow gets
broken out of the matrix again
explaining is just for people who want
to make sense of things and we see that
neo and Trinity are there to greet him
you saved me you saved yourself on the
one hand this could very easily be a
recruitment video for cult trust our
faith drink the kool-aid and off
yourself trust me you'll be okay but I
think the idea behind it is more
dedicating everything you have to
something of value that you truly
believe it and don't get me wrong it is
a little sketchy especially seeing how
the kid commits suicide and gets
rewarded for it at the end I think it's
pretty obvious that's gonna press some
buttons for some people but I'm gonna
make the assumption that's not the
shorts intention the intention is to
create an experience of a rush a rush of
the world around you speeding up slowing
down looking detail looking slow
coppy and all of it building up to this
great big moment of truth it still makes
no sense but it does manage to capture a
true experience you feel the panic you
feel the intrigue you feel the fear you
feel like the adrenalin itself is
putting you in another world and as that
goes it's pretty well directed you can
see every sketch and pencil line in
every second giving a sense of life and
action knowing that every drawing is
done frame by frame it's not just a CGI
puppet that they're moving every motion
is done from scratch and you can feel
the energy off of all of it that alone
makes it really worth watching if not
taking the wrong way it is pretty
impressive to check out the next one is
my absolute favorite it starts off with
a couple sparring in a training program
when one of them offers the other away
out a way to return to the matrix and
live a normal life again what's real
doesn't matter what's important is how
we live our lives but we can't go back
do all we know the truth now we can
forget all of this confused and not
knowing what to do they partake in both
a verbal and physical fight debating
what's the right choice and what isn't
running away one that's running away
this takes up the majority of the short
all leading to a twist ending that I
won't give away here but I personally
thought was a great way to finish this
in my opinion is what the matrix should
be quickly understand these characters
feel their relationship identify with
both sides of their struggle and both
the fighting and visuals match the
emotional impact of what they're going
through there's no shock value or forced
commentary it's just watching these two
people you sympathize with Duke it out
through hardship and sacrifice it's all
you need and is done to the best of its
ability the art work complements a great
the imagination is strong the Fighting's
cool and you're with them every step of
the way what can I say it's hands-down
my personal favor
the next one is pretty well done - once
again focusing more on an experience
than a detailed story world record shows
an athlete who's about to break exactly
that the world record but literally in
being so fast he breaks the chains of
the matrix and actually starts to wake
up and see the truth based only on his
physical abilities it's actually a very
interesting idea the majority of the
short is simply focusing on this
experience but once again it's all you
need you feel the limit this guy is
pushing himself - and you worry both
that he'll either wake up and be
destroyed by agents or that he'll fail
and not break the record at all or even
the third option that he might push him
so so far that he might not even survive
again it's the simplest things that can
be the most effective and both the
pacing and the animation style totally
pull it off it's also an intriguing idea
that you can see another plane simply
based on physical attributes it's been
discussed before by many but this one is
smart enough to know it's a visual
medium and it's better to show it rather
than talk about it and it does a great
job in doing so definitely worth the
time to check out which brings us to
beyond which is probably my second
favorite out of the series again taking
a very simple idea as simply focusing on
the experience of it a young woman and
some kids she stumbles across discover
what is simply defined as a glitch in
the matrix I imagine there's a la those
with all the plot holes these movies
make but once again the majority of the
short is just them interacting with the
glitch they can make time go backwards
change the weather in small areas and
even slow down the world to see it in
all its beauty again the focus is the
experience and it's done with very
simple yet connectable characters it
does go a little abstract near the end
by hinting at something bad I'm not sure
what it is but honestly because it's
mostly a visual experience and it's
obvious there's parts left open to
interpretation I don't mind it
it's kinda like knowing through all
these incredible things that you may go
through in life there's always a dark
troubling side waiting on the other end
that's what I got out of it but maybe it
doesn't mean that at all maybe it means
something totally different I don't know
I feel glad they're leaving it up for us
to decide - said jamming in so much plot
detail that actually makes less sense
the more you describe it good animation
good experience good short next is a
detective story a film noir
about what else a detective trying to
find the infamous Trinity and that's
really about it not much really happens
outside of the search for her but if
you're a fan of dark shadows shady
blinds and alcoholic men and trench
coats it's a fun little story the style
once again is great
grainy dark and dripping in classic film
noir style probably a style over
substance short but the style is so nice
and the substance so not pretentious and
annoying that I think it works out ok if
you like film noir you'll be glad you
check this out and the last one is
definitely a weird one to say the least
it starts out on the surface of the real
world still is apocalyptic as ever as a
rebel is chased down by machines but it
turns out she's part of a team that
captures machines and reprogrammed them
to think they're in a reality where they
need they want to serve mankind sounds
familiar right turning the tables a
little bit they show things like games
entertainment lust identity trust and
all in probably the strangest but still
creatively entertaining way possible you
might be spending half the time asking
yourself why they look like Aeon Flux
and that's because the same desire
worked on both the other half you'll be
wondering what you're even looking at
but still kind of sucked in as to how
they're winning over this machine using
entirely visual means with no dialogue
whatsoever this actually kind of makes
sense all the computer knows it's words
and numbers so getting it to understand
emotions would be more of a visual
experience rather than a verbal one it's
a clever idea with unique layout in a
different way of telling its story and
its ending is something right out of a
gothic tale or a Frankenstein movie
tortured dark and wondering if the right
thing was ever done it could have
benefited from a bit more character but
for what it is and the time frame it has
it's pretty slick and fun to watch it's
out there
that's definitely a short that brings
you along for the ride that makes you
glad that you're up
and that's the Animatrix and is it truly
better than the Matrix movies personally
I think it is true it does have several
bloated moments of self-importance but I
think you'd kind of come to expect that
from the matrix anyway the shorts that
work really work and even the ones that
don't still have so much artistic and
bishan and technical wonder that I'd
still recommend checking them out anyway
visually spectacular with some
interesting ideas if you're looking for
a bit more substance for your Anna money
this is not a bad item to spend
I'm not Nostalgia Critic I remember it
because oh she will never live that down
you